hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
quantitation of free light chains in
serum
and the need for standardization i'm
susie valdez of labyrinths and i will be
your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by
bindingsite to learn more visit them
at us.bindingsite.com
now we encourage you to participate
today by submitting as many questions as
you want during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box
and click send we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well
if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing this presentation
i'd like to now welcome our speaker dr
kaz morata
an associate attending clinical chemist
at the department of
laboratory medicine at memorial sloan
kettering cancer center dr morata
welcome
you may now begin your presentation sir
thank you very much for the kind
introduction uh so as you mentioned
before
my name is kazmirata and i currently
work at the memorial sloan kettering
cancer center
and i will be speaking today on the
quantitation of free light chains and
serum and the need for standardization
the learning objectives of this talk are
three-fold
one to describe the serum free light
chain assay and its role in the
screening
diagnosis and monitoring of patients
with monoclonal demopathies
two to lift different methods by which
free like chains are quantitated
and three to identify issues which
should be considered when switching free
light chain assays
i'd first like to start with a very
brief introduction to multiple myeloma
as that is the disease which is the most
relevant to the quantitation of free
light chains
multiple myeloma is the uncontrolled
growth of the single growth of plasma
cells producing a single immunoglobulin
this clone of plasma cells proliferates
in the bone marrow
and may cause extensive skeletal
destruction
this skeletal destruction is responsible
for osteolytic lesions
osteopenia or thinning of the bone and
or pathologic fractures
you put quite simply multiple myeloma is
a cancer of the plasma cells
so what exactly are plasma cells and
what exactly do they do
plasma cells are mature b cells or b
lymphocytes
once b cells fully differentiate they
tend to reside in the bone marrow
as well as lymph nodes plasma cells are
responsible for synthesizing
immunoglobulins
which play an important role in
protecting the body from infections
most importantly however once these
plasma cells have performed their
function
and cleared their infection they have
been that they have been fighting
these cells are programmed to die off an
abnormality in this process may result
in plasma cell disorders
one of which is multiple myeloma
the pathophysiology of multiple myeloma
is quite complex and i will not be going
into
that deeply here however at its basic
level the cancerous plasma cells cause
damage to multiple organs due to the
overgrowth of neoplastic plasma cells
as well as the overproduction of
immunoglobulins and immunoglobulin
byproducts
which we will discuss in more detail
later
the clinical course of multiple myeloma
is highly variable
although it is generally not a disease
which is curable it is highly
treatable left untreated the average
survival may be approximately six months
fortunately there have been many recent
advances in the treatment of this
disease
this has resulted in significantly
improved survival times
and quality of life for many treated
patients
multiple myeloma is typically treated
with one or more treatment modalities
depending on prognostic factors as well
as response to treatment
treatments typically consist of
chemotherapy autologous hematopoietic
stem cell
transplantation or more recently
targeted therapies
such as anti-ce38 monoclonal antibodies
including daratumumab
or proteasome inhibitors such as
vortezumib
an important aspect of treating multiple
myeloma is the need for monitoring
following therapy
i mentioned before that multiple myeloma
is generally not a curable disease
and patients will inevitably relapse
following any form
of treatment this may occur as soon as a
few months
while some may not relapse for years
once relapse occurs patients may need to
undergo another round of treatment
and in many cases require a change in
the treatment regimen
fortunately given the availability of a
range of therapeutic options
patients can undergo treatment following
multiple relapses
allowing for longer survival
this improves survival however is only
possible due to constant monitoring of
disease to detect relapse of disease
laboratory testing plays a key role in
the management of myeloma patients
due to its ability to detect relapses
in addition to many common laboratory
tests such as basic and comprehensive
metabolic panels
which can detect abnormalities and vital
organs such as the liver and kidneys
certain specific laboratory tests are
used in the monitoring of patients with
multiple myeloma and other monoclonal
gammopathies
one such test is the serum protein
electrophoresis
serum protein electrophoresis is the
electrophoretic separation of the major
proteins dissolved in serum
and is capable of quantitating the m
protein generated by the myeloma plasma
cells
generally the size of the m spike is one
measure of the tumor burden
in myeloma patients
other key tests used in the diagnosis
and monitoring of multiple myeloma
include urine protein electrophoresis
and the serum free light chain assay
the important thing about these two
different assays is that they both
essentially measure the same thing
which is the quantity of free like
chains in patients with
multiple myeloma
so what exactly are free light chains in
order to understand exactly what free
light chains are
it is first important to understand the
structure of the immunoglobulin molecule
immunoglobulins are essentially the life
work of the plasma cell
and are large y-shaped proteins made by
differentiated plasma cells to identify
and neutralize foreign objects
also referred to as antibodies these
proteins are highly specific and are
custom made by plasma cells
following exposure to infections
once made by the plasma cell these
antibodies have the ability to bind
foreign organisms and substances
they can lyse bacteria through the
activation of the complement cascade
neutralize viruses by blocking cell
receptors used by viruses to invade
cells
and activate other immune effector cells
such as macrophages
they essentially serve to clear up
infections or other foreign material
from the body
on this slide is a picture of an
immunoglobulin molecule
the important thing to understand here
is that these immunoglobulin molecules
have a modular structure
the modules in this particular case are
light chains and heavy chains
and in the case of immunoglobulin g the
most common aminoglobulin in the body
is comprised of two heavy chains and two
light chains
i mentioned in a previous slide that
free light chains are important in
monitoring myeloma patients
the term free light chains refers to
light chains that are not bound to heavy
chains as is found in
normal intact immunoglobulin molecules
in healthy individuals like chains are
generally only found in the serum
already bound to other heavy chains
in the form of intact immunoglobulin
molecules and free light
chains are present only in minuscule
quantities
in the case of myeloma however the
cancerous plasma cell clone
being highly dysfunctional produces an
excess of light chains
not all of which may be bound to heavy
chains
other situations in which free like
chains may be elevated
include inflammatory conditions such as
autoimmune disease
infections as well as bone marrow
transplants
finally it should also be noted that
light chains come in two forms
kappa and lambda
so why exactly is the measurement of
free light chains important in myeloma
patients i mentioned previously that the
m spike which is the quantitation of the
total amount of
intact monoclonal immunoglobulin
produced by the cancerous plasma cell
clone
also serves as an indirect measure of
the tumor burden
free like chains are essentially a
byproduct of the m proteins
produced by the myeloma cells
much like a dysfunctional car factory
producing way too many steering wheels
for the number of whole intact
automobiles manufactured
myeloma cells can often generate high
amounts of free like chains in addition
to high amounts of intact and monoclonal
immunoglobulins
a key thing to know about free light
chains is that elevated concentrations
over a
prolonged period can have detrimental
effects on the kidneys due to the
clogging of the renal tubules
it is for this reason that myeloma
patients tend to develop renal failure
as the disease progresses higher
concentrations of free like chains and
myeloma patients
have also been correlated with a poorer
prognosis
finally another important thing to note
about free like chains and myeloma
patients is that approximately 16
of myeloma patients have what is
referred to as free light chain myeloma
this is a situation in which the myeloma
cells have lost the ability to produce
heavy chains to accompany the light
chains being generated
in these cases patients have high
concentrations of monoclonal free light
chains in this term
and these three light chains essentially
become the patients and protein
free white chains were not always
measured in serum
in fact they were first discovered in
1845 by dr william mcintyre of london in
the urine of a 45 year old grocer
alexander mcbean the patient suffered
from severe bone pain and fractures
edema and nephrosis or what we would
typically refer to as nephropathy or
kidney disease
was suspected patient's urine was tested
for the presence of albumin
which indicates damage to the kidney
it was then that it was discovered that
a protein precipitate formed in the
urine
upon warming but then redissolved to 75
degrees celsius
dr mcintyre then had the urine sent to
dr bentz jones
a chemical pathologist at st george's
hospital along with the following note
dear dr bence jones the tube contains
urine of a very high specific gravity
when boiled it becomes highly opaque
on the addition of nitric acid it
effervesces
assumes a reddish hue and becomes quite
clear
but as it cools assumes the consistence
and appearance which you see
heat reliquifies it what is it
although the patient died two months
later
dr vance jones sees this opportunity to
publish his findings regarding this
patient's mysterious urine in the lancet
a british medical journal many of you
may have heard of in 1847.
in this publication dr jones referred to
the protein
as a quote hydrated deutocide of albumin
end quote and noted its significance as
a diagnostic marker
for quote melides ossium or multiple
myeloma as we refer to it today
although dr mcintyre did eventually get
around to publishing his own description
of the urine in 1850
it was dr bence jones who became rich
and famous due to his publication
while dr mcintyre to this day is still
relatively unknown
to this day the presence of free light
chains in urine is referred to as benz
jones proteinuria a hyphen has for some
reason been added between the benson
jones
and people are still unsure of when and
how this occurred as dr bense jones had
no hyphen
in his name
history aside as a present there are
essentially three major methods of
detecting the presence of free like
chains and myeloma patients
urine protein electrophoresis urine
immunofixation electrophoresis
and serum immunoassays
urine protein electrophoresis is one of
the older methods of detecting and
quantitating free-like chains in urine
it indicates the presence or absence of
a monoclonal protein
in the urine in the form of an m spike
the event spikes can be quantitated
and the amount of free light chain
excreted in the urine can be calculated
based on the amount of total protein in
the urine
the problem with this technique is that
due to the variability of urine
concentration with hydration status
this requires a 24-hour urine collection
which is cumbersome for the patient
in addition this method alone cannot
perfectly distinguish between an intact
aminoglybiline and protein and an m
spike caused solely by free light genes
this is because in most healthy
individuals immunoglobulin molecules are
too large to pass through the glomerulus
and do not appear in electrophoretic
analysis of urine
however in patients with myeloma the
kidneys suffer progressive damage over
the course of many years due to the
presence of free like chains
this results in the appearance of intact
immunoglobulin and proteins and
electrophoretic analysis of urine
along with m spikes caused by the
presence of monoclonal free light chains
urine amino fixation electrophoresis is
essentially an extension of urine
protein electrolysis and that involves
the application of antiserum
to a serum to a urine that has been
electrophoretically separated on an
agarose gel
it is able to indicate the presence or
absence of a monoclonal free like chain
as well as identify the type of free
light chain kappa or lambda
the key thing about urine amino fixation
electrophoresis is that it is a
qualitative assay
and is not able to quantitate the amount
of m-protein in urine
it is however due to the fact that it is
an immunoassay more sensitive in its
ability to detect free-like chains in
urine
compared to a simple urine
electrophoresis
urine amino fixation however also has
the same limitations that urine protein
electrophoresis does and that it also
requires a 24-hour urine collection
it was actually not until the 21st
century that a usable test for
quantitative free like chains and serum
came about
although other assays for light chains
did exist they were not specific to free
light chains this created a problem the
serum contains high concentrations of
immunoglobulins
unlike urine which is relatively free of
immunoglobulins due to glomerular
filtration in 2001
immunoassays based on polyclonal
antibodies were developed
that were capable of measuring free
light chains that concentrations present
in serum were developed
the elevation of serum free like chains
in this assay was found to be highly
sensitive
and specific for patients with benz
jones proteinuria
this essay will go on to be
commercialized into a product known as
free light
it should also be noted that this
product was not only a huge commercial
success
but it also but it is also now
incorporated into the international
myeloma working group guidelines for the
diagnosis and management
of patients with multiple myeloma
the freelite assay is an ethylometric
immunoassay
in this system polyclonal antibodies
against free like chains can clump
together to form large immune complexes
which cause the serum solution to become
turbid this results in increased light
scatter through the serum solution
and allows us to quantitate accurately
and precisely the amount of free like
chains
present in serum
the free light assay is fda approved and
is now indicated and widely used for the
following purposes
the diagnosis and monitoring of patients
with non-secretory myeloma and
oligosecretory myeloma
diagnosis and monitoring progress of
patients with lychee myeloma and
amyloidosis
predicting risk of progression in mgus
smoldering multiple myeloma and
plasmacytoma
diagnosis monitoring progress of
patients and prognosis of patients with
intact immunoglobulin multiple myeloma
the serum free light chain assay also
has the interesting characteristic
of not only quantitative free kappa and
free land delight chain blue serum
but also being able to identify the
presence of the monoclonal gramophy
simply by the ratio
of the kappa to lambda-free light chains
it has been demonstrated thoroughly in
large clinical studies that most healthy
individuals have a capital lambda ratio
of 0.26 to 1.65
it has also been shown that people whose
capital lambda ratio fall
outside the 0.26 to 1.65 range
either have a monoclonalphy or multiple
myeloma
furthermore the capital lambda ratio has
proven to also be useful in monitoring
myeloma patients undergoing treatment
the normalization of the capital lambda
ratio is generally considered a positive
response to treatment
the international myeloma working group
which develops guidelines related to the
management of myeloma patients based on
scientific evidence and expert consensus
issued guidelines and recommendations
related to the use of the serum free
light gene assay in multiple
myeloma and related disorders in 2008
these include recommending the use of
the serum free light chain assay for
screening at diagnosis
as well as its use as a potential
replacement for 24-hour urine
electrophoresis
and immunofixation in patients already
diagnosed with light chain amyloidosis
other guidelines include medical
decision limits for serum free light
chain quantitation
and definitions of measurable disease
specifically an involved free light
chain concentration of greater than 10
milligrams per deciliter is considered
abnormal
and part of the definition of measurable
disease
the imwg also incorporates serum free
light chains
results into their uniform response
criteria shown here
to classify patient response to
different therapies and clinical trials
in this classification scheme published
in 2006
serum free like chain quantitation is
included as part of the definition for
partial response
[Music]
more recently in 2014 the imwg revised
its diagnostic criteria for multiple
myeloma to include kappa lambda ratio of
greater than 100
as a myeloma-defining event
this again underscores the importance of
free light chain quantitation
and capital lambda ratios in the
diagnosis and monitoring
of multiple myeloma
as mentioned previously urine protein
electrophoresis and immunofixation
remained the mainstay of detecting
and quantifying light chains until the
advent of serum free light chain assays
even after the arrival of free light
from the binding site
there were no other alternatives
available for a long time
however as of this recording in 2021
there are total of four assays available
for the quantitation of serum free light
chains on the market
these include the free light from the
binding site serolite from sabia
and latex-free light chain from siemens
and the kappa and lambda assays from
diazine
of these four three are fda approved
so this begs the question are results
from different free like chain assays
interchangeable
in the next few minutes i would like to
share with you the results of a study
that we conducted in our laboratory to
answer the question of whether free
light chain assay results
are interchangeable with each other
in our particular study we decided to
compare the traditional gold standard
for free light chain analysis the free
light assay from binding site
with the most recent addition to the
market the diazyme assay
this assay quantitates kappa and lambda
free light chains in the serum and is
quant
compatible with many other automated
amino acid platforms found in clinical
laboratories
this makes this kit highly attractive
for space limited laboratories such as
ours
our study design was as follows first we
set up and validated the diazimaste on
one of our abbott architect
c8000s that we currently use in the
clinical chemistry lab
we then compared the analytical
performance of the diazyme assay with
free light
in a set of 61 msk patients as well as a
separate set of 127 presumed healthy
serum donors
our first study population consisted of
waste serum specimens
from 61 msk patients who had serum
protein electrophoresis immunofixation
and free light testing performed in the
clinical laboratory
information available from these
specimens included free kappa and free
lambda values obtained from the optilite
the kappa de lambda ratio serum or
plasma creatinine levels
igg iga and igm
and m spike values obtained via serum
protein electrophoresis
immunofixation results as well as gender
and age
this slide shows the distribution of
monoclonal gammopathies
among the 61 patients these 61 patients
were selected during the process of
serum protein electrophoresis
interpretation
an inactive attempt was made to get an
even distribution of patients with
monoclonal igg
iga igm and free light chain
monoclonal gammopathies
after analysis of the 61 specimens using
the diazyme assay
it became apparent that the laboratory
would be required to develop its own
dilution protocol for the assay
12 out of the 61 specimens could not be
compared due to missing kappa or lambda
values from the diazyme assay
the missing values were due to an error
output from the c8000
we believe that the error messages were
likely due to capital lambda values
or lambda values exceeding the
analytical measurement range of the
assay based on available data
we then analyze the data from the
remaining 49 specimens which did have
both binding site and diazyme results
shown here is a method comparison plot
between the binding site and diazine
assays for both kappa and lambda
with the binding site or predicate assay
on the x-axis and the diazomaca on the
y-axis
the data shows significant negative
proportional bias at high kappa and
lambda concentrations
this is most likely due to the quote
hook effect or antigen excess
seen in the diazyme assay at high
concentrations
this is also illustrates the need for
implementation of a robust
manual dilution protocol for the divine
assay
in addition to monitoring the quantity
of free kappa or lambda light chains
another key feature of free light chain
assays is the ability to monitor disease
progression using the capital lambda
ratio
for this reason we compared the
concordance of abnormal capital m to
light chain ratios
as many of you are aware there is an
established capital lambda ratio which
is currently used by clinicians to
monitor patients when using the free
light assay
we applied both the 100 diagnostic range
as well as the diazyme recommended
capital lambda
reference range to examine the
concordance of specimens with normal and
abnormal capital lambda ratios
we found in our study that 40 out of 49
patients were in agreement regarding the
abnormal or normal light chain ratios
of the nine that were discordant eight
were found to be normal by free light
and abnormal by the diazyme assay while
one was found to be abnormal by free
light and normal by the diazyme assay
[Music]
the two by two table on the right shows
a similar analysis only this time using
the diadem suggested capital lambda
ratio reference range to determine
abnormality
from results obtained using the diazyme
assay
as you can see the results are identical
this data indicates that the application
of the 100 diagnostic range
or the diazyme suggests a capital lambda
ratio to results obtained from the
diazyme assay
may potentially result in significant
misinterpretation
in the form of false positives
for the second part of our study we took
serum specimens from 127 presumed
healthy donors
and analyzed the specimens on both the
binding site free light and the diazyme
kappa lambda assay
as you can see from the method
comparison plots the comparisons show
relatively high correlation within this
range with both correlation coefficients
above 0.9
however there is a positive proportional
bias of approximately 15 percent in the
kappa
and a negative proportional bias of 20
in the lambda
there also appears to be a constant bias
of approximately 0.3 milligrams per
deciliter in the lambda
another thing we want to examine in the
study was the issue of reference ranges
shown here are the reference ranges for
free kappa free lambda
and the capital lambda ratio established
at the mayo clinic using free light
reagents
also shown is the 100 diagnostic range
for the kappa lambda ratio
which has been shown to be indicative of
the presence of a monolinguality when a
patient has a value outside the range
this range is currently used in clinical
practice worldwide for the purposes of
screening patients for monoclonal
hemopsis
as well as managing myeloma patients
[Music]
in this slide we show the reference
ranges we obtain for measuring 127
presumed healthy donors
based on the central 95 percentile we
find that within our local population
the reference range using the binding
site assay for free kappa is 0.84 to 2.7
milligrams per deciliter and 0.75 to
2.52 milligrams per deciliter for free
lambda
the reference range using the diazimasta
is 0.76 to 3.19 milligrams per deciliter
for kappa
and 0.19 to 1.65 milligrams per
deciliter for lambda
the reference range is proposed by
diazyme and their package insert
is 0.24 to 2.07 milligrams per deciliter
for kappa
and 0.42 to 2.77 milligrams per
deciliter
for lambda
this slide shows the comparison of the
reference range for the kappa to lambda
ratio
obtained by taking the central 95
percent of the values obtained
in the study based on this method the
values obtained from the free light
method
gave a range of 0.66 to 1.82
while the diazyme assay gave a range of
1.1 to 9.96
another interesting thing to note is
that the reference is that the range of
capital
lambda ratios for all 127 donors
with 0.59 to 1.9 for the free light
ratio
while the range using the diazyme acid
give a very wide range of 0.98 to 56.50
these high ratios will be considered
highly abnormal and diagnostic of the
presence
of a monocle engamopti if obtained using
the binding site free light assay
based on the widely accepted 100
diagnostic range for the kappa lambda
ratio
we found that nine of the 127 healthy
donors will be classified as abnormal
if we applied the same criteria i.e the
capital lambda ratio of 0.26 to 1.65
to the value of the values obtained from
the diazime assay
we find that 106 of the 127 donors will
be classified as abnormal
in addition we found that 102 out of 127
donors fell outside the reference range
recommended
for the capital lambda ratio by diazine
which is 0.22 to 1.74
when using the diazyme assay it should
be noted that diazyme currently does not
provide 100
diagnostic range for their assay thus
this is an unequal comparison comparing
the number of patients
falling outside a reference range using
the diazyme assay
with the number of patients falling
outside a diagnostic range
however it is apparent the significant
adjustments will have to be made by
clinical staff
and resolved interpretation when making
a switch from binding site
to diazyme reagents
our conclusions based on this
preliminary study is as follows
use of the diazyme assay will require
the laboratory to develop their own
dilution protocols to analyze specimens
with elevated kappa orlando levels
this is particularly important as free
light chains have a very wide dynamic
range
among patients with myeloma and other
monoclonal homopathies
further dilution may be required even
when the instrument gives a numerical
result as the resulting numbers
may potentially be falsely low
significant discrepancies can be noted
in kappa and lambda quantitation
particularly at high concentrations
significant discordance is seen in kappa
lambda ratios between the binding site
and diazyme assays
both in patients and healthy donors
and finally any medical decision points
based on capital lambda ratios will have
to be redetermined in separate studies
for the divine assay
i would like to end this presentation
with some short take-home messages based
on our experience comparing the two free
light chain assays
it is very important for laboratories to
perform their own validation using
clinical specimens prior to implementing
a new free light chain assay
also free light chain assays as of
present are not identical to each other
nor are they standardized
we believe that caution is warranted
whenever our laboratory is considering a
switch
between free-like chain assays thank you
very much and i'll be glad to take any
questions at this time
thank you dr morata for that informative
presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
if you have any questions you'd like to
ask please do so now
just click on that ask a question box
located on the far
left of your screen and we'll answer as
many questions as we have time for
so let's take a look we already have
some great questions
coming in dr morata can you elaborate
more on the conclusion point that says
further dilution may be required even
when
instrument gives a numerical result as
the resulting number
may potentially be falsely low does this
mean
there are issues with antigen excess
well we we believe that oxygen excess is
probably the most likely cause we did
not specifically you know save the
specimens to do further analysis um
because the way that we did this study
we essentially set up the
instruments based on the instructions
provided by the manufacturer and the
um abbott was the one who set up the
essay for us
um but essentially if the instrument
gave an error
we didn't necessarily we probably should
have done a manual dilution to
determine that it was antigenexis but if
we were to guess it probably is going to
be an antigen excess
as we did an analysis of the we looked
at the specimens that didn't give an
um a numerical value
and that yielded a lot of high uh
values for free like chains especially
for the lambda
so we do suspect that it might
potentially be an antigen excess
yes and and how did you
how did your findings compare to results
from other diazyme evaluations that have
been published
so as far as i'm aware now there may
potentially be more
by now when i last did the literature
search there were two studies that have
been published
one uh by alan wu ucsf and then
another i believe at um from louisville
um and they they have both um sort of
shown that
the uh assays are relatively comparable
but the one thing i want to add is that
at the major cancer center we did a
fairly extensive
evaluation of both healthy and
patients with monoclonal homopathies and
so i we believe that
it's a lot more thorough than what they
did which is just simply
see if the values were relatively
similar we did an analysis including the
ratios
and the clinical significance um and one
thing that's very important with the
capital lambda
analysis is the actual ratio and so when
you do these on
patients and with healthy um donors
you do end up you kind of see where the
um issues are with the um
other assays and so i i think that
we have shown a little bit we kind of
dug a little bit deeper and we
did find that there are some aspects
where
um they're not entirely comparable um
and so we do strongly recommend that
people
um or laboratories do their own
validations um instead of
in thorough evaluations not just ones
that are required from a
clia point of view but clinical
evaluations on real patients to make
sure that
what they're getting both for the
quantitation and the ratios
are similar
thank you so much and i want to thank
our audience again for these great
questions
coming in our next question an audience
member says more than a hundred normal
patients
turned out to be abnormal when tested
using a diazyme test
this number seems high do you have any
explanation
or theory to explain this result
yeah so one of the issues is that
remember
the reference ranges are different for
the two last save now the one thing that
the
binding site has going for it is that it
has a lot of clinical studies behind
it as i showed in the pre some of the
previous slides
for the let me just scroll back to this
slide
hold on
so this is the slide that i kind of
wanted to show um
actually so the interpretation of serum
free light chain results
there have been quite a few large
studies that show that kind of came up
with this sort of 100 percent
diagnostic range that shows that
people who fall within this narrow range
for capital lambda ratio
are essentially uh do not have
monoclocomoxies whereas anybody that
falls outside
general either have an mgus or multiple
myeloma
now with the other assay with the
diazine method they don't have a lot of
the studies behind it
um and so i think if people who want to
use this assay really need to kind of
they need there needs to be another
study a larger study
to establish what that ratio and is
going to be for that particular assay
um i know the the diagram assay was
was fda cleared using the i believe the
501k equivalence
mechanism but it didn't undergo like as
much of the
sort of um it's not quite equivalent
um to the binding site and so
if if people who want to use that essay
are going to need to
really just do their own study involving
hundreds thousands of normal
and donors and patients to sort of
establish
a range that falls into the diagnostic
area and that's separate from the other
potential antigen access issues that we
have encountered
thank you so much and what platform was
used
to run the free light assay was it
run on abbott um actually so the one
thing about
so the plus and the minus of the three
light assay is that
um so the binding site actually controls
um
specifically what instrument it's run
it's run on for and there's
actually probably now that we've run it
on the abbott
instruments i think it kind of makes
sense
the if you're not careful with the
bindingside assay you can
end up with antigen excess as well too
and i published on this before but those
are relatively rare and the reason why
is because
they actually do have an instrument
called the um
[Music]
i tried blanking on the name it's the um
it used to be the binding site spa but
now it's the um
uh optilite and the the opulent is
actually programmed
specifically to prevent the antigen
excess
and so all the binding site assays are
run
on the optilite which is specifically
programmed
for running the binding site assays and
also to prevent
the antigen excess issues
that could potentially be encountered
thank you so much dr morada we have time
for one more question
for error messages exceeding amr
were they above or below amr
[Music]
we believe that they were probably above
the amr it's just that
i think with when you run the essay on
these sort of other third party um
manufacturers sometimes it's
because there's other um
for example on the when you run the free
light on the optilite there are
mechanisms in place to prevent
to detect um the antigen excess
when you run assays on other platforms
such as
the architect or other third party um
instruments there is no specific
mechanism to detect it so
even though a result may be outside
the amr you don't all the machine might
potentially falsely detect it as within
the amr
by antigen excess and so
we believe that the result that we got
probably were outside the amr it just
wasn't detected as being
outside the amr um because it just
didn't have the sort of safety
mechanisms in place to prevent
um the machine from
letting a result through without
recognizing the potential antigen access
[Music]
dr morata i want to thank you so much
for your presentation today
would you like to provide our audience
with any
closing remarks before we go
sure um as i mentioned in my closing
slide i think
one of the things that's very important
for labs or laboratories is that
when you do have an assay on the market
i think it's very important the
validation is important not just from a
regulatory viewpoint
but also from a patient care perspective
for those laboratories that do want to
switch or are planning on switching
and this is not just for free like chain
assays but for any other assay
i think it's very important that they do
consult with the clinicians
they inform the clinicians that they do
plan out switching and that they do
the switch in collaboration with them
because as we've seen in this particular
example
you could end up with a situation where
you have um
clinicians kind of confused with the
interpretation of the results
and i think by working with the clinical
staff in terms of
when you do these switches you tend to
prevent any sort of future
problems that may potentially occur as a
result
of an assay switch and so i think it's
very important for clinical labs to
definitely do their own validation both
using clinical
specimens as well as healthy donors and
also
work with your clinical staff
the people who see the patients so that
there's no misunderstanding in terms of
you know when you do switch uh assays
that the clinicians don't notice hey we
we notice that there's an uptick in the
number of
um abnormal normal patients
we don't know what's going on so that's
one thing that i would like to
definitely
put out to the laboratorians out there
dr morada i want to thank you again for
your time today for your important
research
and i want to also thank lab roots and
our sponsor binding site for
underwriting today's educational
webcast and before we go i want to thank
our audience for joining us today and
for their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period
will be addressed by our speaker via the
contact information
you provided at the time of registration
and this webcast can be viewed
on demand lab routes will alert you via
email when it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
that's all for now and thank you for
joining us until next time
stay safe and stay healthy goodbye
everyone